with
me
[Music]
smile
s
[Music]
things
come out
[Music]
um
thank you
[Music]
I'm pretty sure
I thrifted these two
yeah
this is this is Thrifty two it's some
random company
I just I just like critics
they're fun the material was good
[Music]
you look
at this
[Music]
these like aren't like Gene materials
good evening
good evening table lights
seven seconds oh
three two one
[Applause]
official happy New Year Happy
Valentine's Day welcome to the table
Kelly I'm so glad you guys are here
tonight whether you're online here in
person thanks for making the choice to
be here I'm genuinely so glad that you
have if this is your first time way to
be brave and show up that's not easy but
you've done it so welcome
um I have a few announcements for us
next Wednesday Begins the lint Linton
season we'll be meeting here if you
would like to kick that off with
Pleasant Valley at seven o'clock that
evening so join we'll be joining in with
them so join if you'd like and then next
Saturday is it on Saturday the state of
the table is an online or is it right
after church okay I think you will get
more information about that so don't
don't worry about my sketchy information
right now
next Sunday right after church it'll be
available online state of the table
meeting which is just like a family
meeting where we go over the yearly
goals leadership transitions who we are
why we are who we are and just kind of
like a you know a rebuttal into another
year of doing life together and serving
the community and those around us so
would love for you to join online there
will be um if you don't get Brett's
weekly text message you should because
it's so encouraging always the loveliest
prayers that are just like oh I needed
that so if you don't get that text on
your way out tonight you can sign up
um the little cards right outside of the
room and get those texts where you will
also get more information about what
time that meeting is happening
and other meetings going forward
um
so yeah we'd love for you to join us and
to learn more about our community if
you're interested in that way then hop
online next Sunday night and join us
the table was birthed with
um
some heartbeats that that really are the
Rhythm that we move to and that is
um
oh my gosh I just completely went blank
thoughtfulness
[Music]
so these are our shirts
thoughtful thoughtful inclusive eclectic
communal and vulnerable the heartbeat of
this church
[Applause]
and so you can also spell out the word
evict and it it will do all those words
as well
and I could not remember but evict has
nothing to do
done I'm glad you're here
um let's all just take
laughs what a weird word
let's just take a deep breath together
into your nose
out through your mouth we're all smiling
I think it's a great night to be here
there's peace there's joy it's yours and
may we bask in that together in the
Lord's presence meet you here tonight
guide you where you need to go in the
the next couple days the next couple
hours maybe even just the next couple
minutes may you feel that Spirit of joy
and peace and it just bless you with
gratitude as you enter another week of
loving God loving others and loving
yourself
[Music]
thanks Cal
why don't you guys stand with us we're
gonna start off with worship like we do
Gary's actually going to begin us with
glorious day and I just am inviting you
guys
um As we sing out this song
um just to maybe have kind of an
imaginative approach if you will like a
child who pretends who enters that
imaginary place in their mind where they
can see themselves as something other
than what they are and and whatever it
is tonight that you could be bringing
into the space that's a struggle I just
invite you to imagine something beyond
that struggle imagine if you are
experiencing sadness or depression
imagine the joy of God meeting you here
if you are imagining anxiety
um or if you're struggling with that
imagine that his peace is flooding into
you slowly and filling up every cell of
your body
um and believe that he is calling you
into that he is calling you into a space
beyond what we can see and what we can
touch and feel and what's right in front
of us he is bigger and if there's
anything I've learned about the love of
God and the way of Jesus is that he is
beyond what I know he is beyond what I'm
experiencing here in this moment so
let's tap into that together and hold
that space for each other
all right
I was very
beneath my shame
who could carry that kind of ways
it was my too
till I met you
[Music]
this is
you call my name
[Music]
out of the darkness into your glorious
day
my soul
now your freedom is on
did I know
because
[Music]
girl my name
is
all right sing us out with us
[Music]
out of the dark Ness
your glorious day
can you call my name
foreign
[Music]
thank you guys kiddos we will see you
after the service they can go on to
their classrooms
okay
[Music]
Caitlyn is going to lead us in the
prayers of the people and if you guys
would just offer up the names or the
situations that are heavy on your heart
and if you're online leave those in the
comments when she gives you the space to
do so and we will share those here in
the room as well
[Music]
for the city of Sachse Texas and for
every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you
for The Good Earth you have given us and
the wisdom and will to conserve it we
pray to you for the old and the sick for
the Widow and orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to you for the poor
and the oppressed the unemployed and
destitute for prisoners and captives and
all who remember and care for them we
pray to you for the vulnerable the
marginalized and those unjustly targeted
for their gender sexuality race or other
perceived difference we pray to you for
those experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you
Lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us and so we lift these names
in situations up to you
Johnny Owen
[Music]
Charles
foreign
[Music]
for the names and moments we have spoken
aloud and for those we have kept in our
hearts we pray to you that they may have
life and light healing and hope peace
and a deep sense of your presence amen
[Music]
thank you
come to the water
all who are thirsty
come and drink
come to the table
all who are hungry
come and feel
[Music]
those who are weary
those who are needing
[Music]
[Applause]
me
[Music]
love
come taste and see
[Music]
come to the waters
[Applause]
[Music]
eating
come with me
come to the river
Come to the River
taste and see
oh
my soul
there's foreign
[Music]
and I will taste and see these are good
I will
taste and see that you are good
good to me
[Music]
I will taste and see that you are good
I will chase
[Music]
and see
I will say
you are good
I will taste and see this
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
my soul
[Music]
come to the wider
all who are
[Music]
thirsty
come and dreams
come to the table
all who are hungry
[Music]
come and feed
s
[Music]
God thank you for making room for each
one of us
for inviting us in to your love
[Music]
you brought me to the end of myself
and this has been the longest
just win my Hallelujah was tired
you gave me a new song
[Music]
I'm Letting Go
falling into
I confess I still get scared
sometimes
but perfect love comes rushing in
and all the lies
are screamed inside
foreign
[Music]
I'm letting
go
[Music]
and you remind me
of things
around me fear was no match for your
love and now you've won me
[Music]
you remind me
of things
[Applause]
I'm living
I am
[Music]
falling into you
I'm Letting Go
I am letting go
[Music]
falling in
here
[Music]
Jesus in all the areas where I want to
grab so tightly
[Music]
told the outcome
in all the areas where I'm afraid
where I allow fear to creep in
God would you help me to open my hands
you help me to breathe
and trust your goodness
and your love to carry us through
[Music]
how would you remind us to take to take
space
to take account of our reactions and our
responses
to sit back and reflect
to make room for you to speak to us
[Music]
but listen
for that still small
to be still and know that regardless of
what's going on in my small world that
you are God
[Music]
thank you
would we give you the space to do your
work in our lives
[Music]
and when we trust you to bring it to
completion
to continue it
foreign
us would it carry us
[Music]
would we become more like Jesus
I thank you
thank you for carrying us
for being present with us
and our joy and in our pain
[Music]
would we lean into it
we love you Jesus meet with us tonight
amen
as you guys settle in first would you
just turn to the people around you
welcome them make them feel at home
and Brett's Gonna Get Us started on our
message thanks for worshiping with us
all right well Grace and peace it is
good to uh good to be with you all so so
good and
um
I'm glad you all are here at five I
always get a little nervous after we
start changing times last week because
of the great cultural event known as the
Super Bowl
and uh yeah I don't know but here you
all are so I'm glad there's no confusion
uh so um I want to welcome you all but
that is especially true for anyone who
is new and uh joining us so glad to have
you with us and
um also those joining us online love you
lots you're not at all forgotten so yeah
y'all want to give them a little wave a
little I like y'all we like you online
um so we are let's see we're in uh the
fifth and the final
um part of our series titled rooted
grounded discipleship so
um we've well next week we're beginning
lint we got Ash Wednesday coming up I
hope you all are here seven o'clock uh
Wednesday for that and uh and then you
know next Sunday of course we'll be into
the first Sunday of Lent
um so that'll be a whole new whole new
thing we're gonna be talking about the
cross and all that I have um I've been
doing some research and stuff on those
messages and I'm very excited very
excited so
um but tonight's we're wrapping up our
series rooted and um you'll recall like
what this was we had a youth Sunday in
here so even though the series was five
weeks Tenley it's been like you know six
weeks so like six weeks ago um the first
message was kind of an intro to the this
just the series as a whole and we talked
about how we kind of inhabit this
culture right now of um just looseness
like loose connections to uh everything
and everyone uh from you know places
like the way we all just kind of move
around you know and like we're kind of a
rootless people uh so that kind of
spills over into all sorts of like
community and relationships you know
where it's um we're sort of you know
friends for a season you know while
we're in town or whatever and then it's
like we're off to the next thing every
you know three years or whatever
um and it plays out in terms of um
family even there you know extended
families uh are very like disconnected
and even nuclear families you know it's
like
um it's it's kind of tough to stay
together and uh that's you know just it
you can just see where this keeps
Rippling out and having this effect and
of course that applies to uh to our
relationship with God
um as well where we um I'm getting some
feedback Josh maybe that's just me but
um I'm kind of hearing it
um
so right where it's sort of like we're
committed to God you know for now we're
like in you know we're Christians
sort of you know and of course I think
if you've been here a while you know we
have all the room in the world for uh
seasons of questions and deconstruction
and that's you know necessary and good
um but there does also come a point
where it's it's good to be rooted you
know it's good to like commit and say
okay God I'm trusting that I can grow
where you're planting me in this world
in this life um and even for our context
like here in this you know in this
church community so um that's kind of
you know where we've been going so the
whole idea of the series was to give you
some practices for how to do that so we
talked about how to pray how to read
scripture last week was how to fight uh
as in like navigate conflict
um and then this week the title of the
message is how to live how to live
um which sounds really broad but
hopefully it'll make sense so I want to
start with our scripture this is John
chapter 15 verses four through nine uh
famous passage from from Christ self
he says this abide in me
and I in you
as the branch cannot bear fruit by
itself unless it abides in the Vine
neither can you unless you abide in me
I am the vine you are the branches
whoever abides in me and I in him he it
is that bears much fruit for apart from
me you can do nothing if anyone does not
abide in me they're thrown away like a
branch and they wither the branches are
gathered they're thrown into the fire
and burned that if you abide in me in my
words abide in you ask whatever you wish
and it will be done for you
by this my father is glorified that you
bear much fruit and so prove to be my
disciples
as the father has loved me so have I
loved you abide in my love
so what is the secret
the secret to bearing much fruit in this
life
what's the secret to to bearing the
fruit of of a life of love and joy and
peace and patience and kindness and
goodness and gentleness and faithfulness
and self-control
or we might reverse it and ask what is
the secret to like at the very least
bearing less bad fruit
because I mean frankly a lot of days I
would settle for that like even if I
can't like radiate love and goodness
everywhere I go you know at least I can
like stop losing it on people you know
primarily my kids uh like after 8 PM I
just lose all the grace uh you know like
what how I would settle for that you
know at least be neutral I think the
heck of the world would be a lot better
if we could all just at least be neutral
um so what's the secret
uh and you might even say what's the
secret to living because you'll notice
the context here is is life in general
it's not uh specific to abide you know
when you are on a spiritual pilgrimage
uh when you are at church from five to
six pm on Sundays or uh when you're on a
personal Retreat or when you're on
vacation you got something
no no the context is just our life so
what what's the secret it is of course
Jesus says to abide
to abide over and over and over again he
says it I wrote this down it was like if
you count it up it's three times in
verse four it's once in verse five it's
once in verse six it's twice in verse
seven it's once again in verse nine
abide abide abide abide abide abide the
way a branch rests in and remains
connected to its root Vine
abide in in that way
and uh of course the only way for that
Branch to bear fruit as Jesus says is to
remain connected you would you would
never suspect if you saw like this you
know beautiful kind of trellis in this
Vine I'll go and you saw like this
Fallen Branch off the side completely
disconnected you would never expect like
walk up the next morning and be like oh
my gosh grapes and grapes are everywhere
on that thing of course not you gotta
you gotta remain it's got to remain
connected to the Vine
and uh so I guess that kind of drives
the question you know because we can
read passages like this and we're kind
of like oh yes okay
just abide abide in Christ
and then we're like
I don't know what that means
you know what I mean like it's sort of
like oh of course just abide abide in
the presence of of the Lord friends like
okay do I need to
I just need to say God a lot again I
just walked through life just God you
know you know I don't know like you know
it can be a little fake
um so what I want to do I'm going to
draw a lot from kind of broader
Christian resources
um and theologians and I have a number
of quotes and things to kind of unpack
like what
does this mean no you're not alone we're
not like making Christianity up like
right now and we've got 2 000 years of
people reflecting on stuff like this
so like let's draw from you know from
those Wells so tonight I've got uh three
things to share with you three things to
kind of unpack what what does it mean to
abide so if you're a note taker you can
jot this one down first to abide is to
learn the art of resting in God
is to learn the art of resting in God
you can kind of hear it even in the word
itself abide right when you when you
think of someone like abiding you don't
get a picture of like strive
striving worry
you know worry constantly that that
you're not abiding you're like no no no
right to to abide is you get this
picture of
um of rest
and a kind of non-anxious
posture in the world I was thinking
about the broader culture and I think
probably in in modern culture the only
place I can think that I've ever heard
the word abide
is in The Big Lebowski has been anyone
when I started saying all this abide
language or something like this just to
be clear I'm not endorsing The Big
Lebowski haven't seen it in seven years
I don't even know what's in it I'm sure
there's bad things plenty of bad okay so
I'm not suggesting it
I do remember it was funny
um but if you've seen it you know the
main character uh so his he's ref he's
called the dude
I can't remember if he has another name
I don't know just the dude and his
statement is for the phrase is the Dude
abides
and sure enough
he does
like the whole movie so basically he's
just going through these ridiculous
situations like things that for the
anxious Among Us it would stress you out
and the whole time I mean it's he is so
non-anxious it will drive you crazy
you're just like oh my gosh man you've
got to take control of your life you
know he's just like oh I don't know man
like he just goes all these ridiculous
things just the dude advice and I guess
what I'm getting at is as Christians
we've got to learn to be a little bit
more like the dude in that way now just
to be clear not his if you've seen the
movie his irresponsibility his childness
his immature not in those ways
but just that non-anxious
like receiving life as it comes
because so often we're just fighting our
life we're just like in opposition to it
it's like this just shouldn't be but it
is we're like but it shouldn't be and I
don't like it
you know
give you a little definition to abide
is to spend our days in a restful
attentive awareness
of the presence of God
because only from that place can we
begin to live in peace only from that
place can we finally rest only from that
place does our anxiety and our
restlessness quiet uh just slowly
slowly but surely begins to quiet down
there's a quote I came across from
Richard Rohr and it was sent to me by
Mendy
my sister-in-law or worship leader and
then but she received it from Adam
because Adam has been he will send out a
text in its quotes from this awesome
devotional he's been reading and it's
from Richard Rohr and so that's the
connection I'm just giving all the
credit as I can
I adore this quote this is so good Roar
said this we must not push the river
we must just trust that we are already
in the river
and God is the certain flow and current
not good I love the image of you cannot
push the river like that would be absurd
would it not like you're in the river
and you're like come on
come on I mean if you saw if you were on
the bank of a river and you saw someone
out on the river and they're like hurry
up River hurry up you just be like oh my
gosh hey hey are you okay you know like
do you
do you need something you need someone
you know it's like they're not well
right if you're like well no no River I
don't want to go this way I want to go
that way no Upstream River not
Downstream it's just like no no this is
not gonna work this is not how rivers go
you can't you can't push the river you
can't force the river
um and said what do you do like when
you're in a river you just you receive
it and you you move
with it and this is part of what it
means to start learning to rest in God
is is in essence like to receive your
life as the gift that it is
and and even to work with it because I
realize there could be maybe
circumstances of like say abuse or you
know something where I'm not saying just
you know everything that happens just
utterly say like oh it is the will of
God right that's that's not that's not
quite what I'm saying
um instead I'm saying like don't don't
fight
your life
rest
relax
um stop trying to control so much
and and work with the river as it is so
that's first what does it mean to abide
we've got to learn to the art of resting
in God second to abide is to allow the
spirit inspired response to arise
um you know all this talk about abiding
in Christ and just going with the river
you know it can kind of sound like oh so
I just I don't do anything I just rest
you know um no uh of course like we live
we have to act we we have to um we have
to do things of course
um
but I think what this is kind of getting
at is we might say it like this that the
quality of our capacity to abide to kind
of remain in that restful attentive
awareness to God's presence
um that that ends up determining the
quality of our actions of our responses
like like the skillfulness
to which uh or or in which through which
we like speak
or offer someone perspective
or do a thing or decide not to do a
thing or
um not to speak which can sometimes be
just as important as
choosing to speak right can you see
where
um like when we're in this kind of aware
living with this awareness
suddenly life like gets a little bit
easier because we're in that River and
we're allowing the spirit of God to just
determine what is done and what is said
um in each moment there's of course
Christ alludes this in verse 5 and he
says I'm the vine you're the branches
whoever abides in me and I in him he it
is that bears much fruit for apart from
me you can do nothing right that word
nothing I don't think it's overly
literal like if you're not abiding then
literally you're Frozen you're like oh I
can't do anything I must not be abiding
right obviously it's it's in in the
sense of um no good fruit comes from
that
right we've got to remain in God's
presence and when we do that like
suddenly the spirit inspired word the
spirit inspired response the action
that's needed like
it it starts to happen uh and of course
this applies like in so many areas from
uh I mean I'm in the parenting season of
life so I'll roll with that analogy or
that example again uh I can tell when
I'm parenting and I'm not in the spirits
can you have you ever parented not in
the spirit
yeah you know it's uh it is not great
it's not not great
um
it even I think this applies beautifully
in the area of art if you're kind of
wondering like oh this sounds a little
vague I don't quite know what it means
to like allow the spirit inspired
response to arise I mean have you ever
been there needing to create something
but and maybe you have like some ideas
or something but ultimately you don't
really know what you are going to do
and you simply
come to that Medium you know whether
it's like paint or writing or music you
know what you come to that Medium
and then what happens
like
something arises
now you say well how do I know if it's
like if it's the spirit of Christ how do
I know if it's like the God who is
Father son's Spirit kind of full like
the the life source of everything that
is how do I know when that like when I'm
really abiding in that that response
that Spirit inspired response is coming
forth how do you know you know it by the
fruit is it is it true and beautiful and
powerful and timely and relevant and
helpful and encouraging and uplifting
like if so you got it like you're in the
flow right and artists among us know
like there's this weird I mean people
often ask me like how do you write you
know sermons how do you do this week
after week you just have something to
say you know and um the truth is I mean
obviously I do some like research and
kind of think it through but ultimately
I've learned because I only have a week
every time you know like the clock's
ticking so I just sit down and sometimes
I'll have like not much
and I just I don't know
you just you just start writing like uh
and then you all of a sudden know like
no backspace backspace you know what I
mean like no no no and then you just
all right I mean I I had this experience
actually just this week I'm working I
told you about lent and you know I try
to stay a little bit ahead so I'm not
stressed out basically I don't wanna I
wanna abide but it's hard for me to buy
it if I'm right in the week of so you
know I'm a little bit ahead and so I'm
writing this thermal across but the
truth was I'd already written one that I
loved and it's kind of like oh now I
need a second thing to say about the
cross hmm okay I'm not quite sure where
I'm gonna go and I had that experience
this week or just kind of like oh am I
okay
all right yeah like all of a sudden it
just have you had this experience all
right maybe you're like I'm not an
artist I don't have anything to do this
well how about like conversation
think of how conversations happen like
you go into the conversation I mean at
least a good conversation shouldn't be
scripted that's a very weird you know
because what do you do like you just get
there
and what's the key like got to be
present
right present not too lost in like
future or the past or right just present
and then what happens
the words
where do they come from it's a mystery
even neuroscientists don't totally know
like how how does your brain work it's
just amazing just the spirit inspired
responses just start to
right this in essence think of it kind
of like that like this becomes your
whole life again not that you don't plan
or prepare or whatever but you you do
start to come into this this mode of
um learning to to abide and Trust
trust that the words will be given you
trust that the wisdom you need it will
be it will be given to you this is
genius by the way when you're in the
midst of conflict we talked about this
last week
when you're really like the key is of
course to work through all those
feelings because once you can enter a
more peaceful place
then suddenly you just trust the spirit
of God to like lead you and bring the
healing words that or the truthful Words
which can be ultimately healing
sometimes they're not always comfortable
but at least the truth um can begin to
to happen
so all right so that's
um that's second all right third uh what
does it mean to abide to abide is to
rest in a quiet mind
a quiet mind that connects us to the
great mind which is of course another
word for phrase for God
um
in a sense abiding to abide is to sink
ever more deeply into that that
quiet-centered place
oh this is what the the Christian monks
they call it watchfulness
which I think is a marvelous word it's
it's sort of a deep watching of yourself
and others in the world
where you're like very attentive and
tuned in another word would be presence
it's what the Buddhist monks they call
it mindfulness at least in America
um though that turn of phrase even a lot
of them don't necessarily like it
because it makes it sound like full of
mind
which you know it just sounds like a oh
busy mind thinking a lot it's like oh no
not exactly it's actually the opposite
so it's a strange word but you can see
what it's trying to get at it's trying
to name a certain
presence
and in it's a
it's less churning on the the thinking
thinking thinking thinking thinking
thinking which is happening almost all
the time
in our minds isn't it that you know that
running commentary
in your brain which really I was
thinking about
um you know like the what would be the
opposite of this quiet mind that would
be we talked again about this last week
it would be the Mind Set On Fire by
um anger and rage and how your mind just
starts churning like stories and
judgments and commentaries and like it's
just like you know I mean so in essence
if you're kind of like I'm not sure what
he means think of the opposite of that
the opposite of that like like the
opposite of that would be
um to enter into presence to like for
example to be here
and I hope to just be here
present
in a pretty quiet mind hopefully you're
not maybe I mean maybe there's some
commentary like how long is this gonna
go you know it's been a while since he
told a story you know I don't know
um right so but but all in all it's it's
to be present once we start doing that
and get a little bit quieter mind oh
like this is where peace starts to
um
find us in such such beautiful ways
there's a quote this is from the 15th
century Christian monk we don't know who
it was
um might have been a monk or none but
the writer said this remember this
simple truth you are as you are
I think that's back to the being the
river thing you are as you are
let thinking go
and this brings us back to verse 9 where
Jesus said as the father has loved me so
have I loved you abide in my love it's
so beautiful to like enter a place where
you don't feel like you have to
constantly figure out your life
like make sense of everything explain
everything fix everything or everyone
which is often like I'd be happy if I
could just fix all these people around
me
[Laughter]
um
no that's that's not abiding to abide is
to entrust yourself to the one who made
you and knows you and loves you and to
entrust others
to the one who knows them loves them
made them
and and from that begins to to flow a
certain um a deep deep
so in closing the art of living as a
Christian is really the art of of being
that's what we've been talking about
tonight being
resting in God resting in Christ not
being anxious about what we'll do but
allowing that Spirit inspired response
to to arise not getting lost in thinking
thinking thinking
but returning to God's presence and
letting every thought and worry go
go so tonight
the beautiful thing about this practice
is that you can begin
right now
that's kind of cool huh I mean a lot of
the Assurance kind of like this week I
hope you I mean you right now
here we are
and we're going to come to the table of
the Lord
and I don't know what thoughts normally
go through your mind you know I don't
know you're like man it's getting late
I'm hungry or maybe then you're grateful
you're like oh at least it's a little
something
um uh or you know I don't know I don't
know or maybe you know because of past
Church experiences you like these kind
of times make you nervous like oh all
the guilt hits me you know I don't I
don't know what's what's going on but
let that go
and just be here
so as we come to take the bread
it's the body of Christ let it nourish
let it fill you let it connect you to
him and as we drink this wine
may it be the blood of Christ that
nourishes and heals and sustains and
sets you on a path of faith hope and
love this this week that's my prayer for
you so we practice what's called an open
table
here at the table
and that just means if you're here
tonight and you want to participate in
communion you do it you are welcome
there's there's no one like you know are
you a member here or uh I don't know
do you do
you with all our theology you know we're
just if you have a hunger in you for
christ then you're welcome you you come
forward to participate the bread is
gluten free the red is true real wine
and the white is grape juice if that's
your thing but the way we're going to do
this is we'll just form one line right
here I'm kind of starting from the front
front and then we'll just work our way
back and you can just partake whenever
you'd like No One's Gonna like lead you
through the taking so you can do that
immediately or return to your seat and
partake there so this is the table not
of the church
but of the Lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more so come
you who have much faith and you who have
little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long
you who have tried to follow and you who
have failed
come
because it's the Lord Jesus himself who
invites you
and it's his will that those who want to
meet him should meet him here
come to the table
[Music]
foreign
take as much time as you need to finish
your moment of communion but when you do
if you would like to stand with us we're
going to end with sort of one of our
table theme songs I love the words of
this song Just because it speaks to the
inclusivity of Jesus and the space that
he makes for each one of us so you guys
sing along if you know it
[Music]
thank you
come all proud
come on lies
come all ashamed
I'll always
[Music]
come on
see
[Music]
[Applause]
every race
[Music]
[Applause]
come and stay cause
[Music]
[Applause]
you're never stranger
[Music]
it's coming
tell me
[Music]
is coming
now
I'm ready
[Music]
let's go live out the mission
there's a kingdom
[Music]
okay guys Brett y'all I feel like this
was such an exciting sermon kind of like
just an Anthem to go into the week of
like these are the things that we get to
step into we get to have because of God
within us flowing out of us into the
world and it's not just the peace that
we get to abide in it's also the power
the power of love of selflessness of
giving of listening and just learning
it's really exciting and I just felt so
much joy sitting there tonight listening
and thinking I get to go this week and
be loved and give love just as I am just
as you are and I just think there's so
much so much greatness in that and I
really hope and pray that as you leave
here tonight you do walk out in that
Spirit of restfulness and that posture
but also in the posture of power of who
God is and what God has done through his
son for you
um don't forget next Wednesday we start
the Linton season here with Pleasant
Valley there will be more information
through that in the email or the text
from Brett if you don't receive that
please fill out a card on your way out
and we would love to connect with you in
that way also right after the service if
you need someone to pray with you or hug
you
or just stand with you I'll be at the
back and would love to be in that space
with you
um usually we have a beautiful
benediction that our good friend Karen
wrote and tonight I thought as we walk
out these doors in that peace and in
that power I thought
I'm going to read a line and if you feel
comfortable say it whisper it right
after me you can close your eyes open
with your hands open with a posture of
just receiving what I'm saying or you
can definitely
repeat after me over your own heart or
the person next to you whichever you
feel is best for you
I am a child of God
this is true on my best day
[Music]
this is true on my worst day
I am loved
I am worthy
just as I am
[Music]
I can be love and I can give love
I can be joy and I can give joy
[Music]
I can be peace and I can give peace
I can be patient and I can give patients
[Music]
I can be kind and I can receive kindness
I can be generous
[Music]
I can be faithful
I can be gentle
and I can practice self-control
go now in the power and the love and the
grace and the goodness the light the
love the fruit of the spirit our Jesus
there Jesus all of our Jesus and have a
wonderful week
God go before us
in Jesus name amen
[Music]
come and accepted
come on
come now come
come
now come
on
it was the same outro